currently covet vaccines are only given
to children
aged 12 and over in the uk who have
underlying health conditions or live
with those
at high risk last month the joint
committee on vaccination
and immunization said it wouldn't extend
that to other children
as it wanted time to examine extremely
rare reports
of inflammation of heart muscles in
young adults
who'd had the pfizer or moderna jabs
especially
as covid19 rarely causes severe illness
in healthy youngsters but now
it has decided to recommend vaccines to
all
16 and 17 year olds in the uk
saying the benefits outweigh the risks
to not only protect the teenagers
themselves
but also to dampen any further waves of
infection
ahead of schools reopening in september
about 1.4 million teenagers will be
involved
in the new rollout but many experts
argue it should be extended
to younger children as well i asked the
jcvi
why it isn't prepared to go that far
yet if it's a safe vaccine for that
cohort the 12 to 15 year olds
and you're saying you're seeing some
very sick patients admitted
would now not be a good time to start
including them in your program
ahead of the autumn term not only to
protect those children to
break that chain of transmission in the
classroom
what we haven't yet decided definitively
on
are the otherwise healthy 12 to 15 year
olds who are
at very much lower risk of some of these
severe outcomes we're talking about
and we will review the data and the data
allow
then we will obviously want to try and
protect them with vaccination as well
but it is already happening elsewhere in
the past week
ireland and germany have announced they
are going to offer vaccines to
all 12 year olds and over the usa and
canada have been doing so since may
and other countries where children 12
and over can get a jab include
france italy china and israel
the jcvi says its guidelines are kept
under
constant review and nothing is ruled out
or
in for the future